what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and things just got super exciting for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as it
looks like we just got the reveals for
two major upcoming MCU villains One for
the blade movie and another for upcoming
groups like The Midnight Suns and other
Supernatural projects where this person
is going to be the villain for Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios
has been talking about for a while and
we are going to be seeing different
sides to the MCU of course we're gonna
have our very grounded Earthly Avengers
team but to take it even further than
that we are going to have a street level
Avengers team as well these characters
will consist of Spider-Man The Punisher
Daredevil Etc then we're going to have
our Cosmic side of the MCU and we're
about to further explore this side of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe with the
next two MCU movies that are coming out
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 and the
Marvels but then we have the
supernatural side of the MCU and this is
a side of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that a lot of fans are really looking
forward to now it's already gotten off
to a start with Doctor Strange and then
of course we got our special
presentation werewolf By Night further
diving into a true Supernatural and
Mystic side of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and it looks like we might
actually know now who the main big bat
is of the supernatural side of the MCU
now just so you're aware each kind of
subunit of the MCU will indeed have
their own big bad villains so to speak
for example the street level Avengers
team with Spider-Man Daredevil Echo and
The Punisher their villain is going to
be Kingpin he is going to appear in
multiple different projects movies and
shows and be the villain for many
different characters he's already
appeared in the Hawkeye series being a
villain there and he'll be the main
villain in the Echo series and the
Daredevil series as well and it said
that he is going to show up in some
Spider-Man projects as well so we pretty
much have our big bad for the street
level side of the MCU and like I said it
looks like we could have our big bat or
at least one of them for the
supernatural side with an official
announcement as a actor has just been
cast by Marvel Studios to play a very
important role she's been cast for blade
but it looks like she's going to be
sticking around in the MCU for quite
some time it's also looking like this
could be the start of the midnight Suns
which I know everybody is super excited
about so this character means a lot for
the future of the MCU and if you want to
stay up to date on the MCU be sure to
subscribe and if you subscribe and leave
a comment down below you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series
X some Marvel Legends stuff some DC
stuff Winner's Choice and we pick a
winner at the end of each month now you
might have recently heard that Marvel
Studios has cast Mio goth for the blade
movie now Mia goth is known as a
breakout star in the horror genre of
film so it's pretty fitting that they
would cast her for a very dark and
Supernatural movie Blade so that's a
great and exciting choice however the
real kicker is who she's going to be
playing now with the announcement that
she had been cast for blade they did not
announce the official character she
would be playing however many different
insiders including The Insider my time
to shine hello who has a great track
record came out and said Mia goth is
going to be playing the character Lilith
and this is a really big deal and it
also kind of tells us who the main
villain of blade is going to be but more
importantly Lilith could serve as a big
bad of the supernatural side of the MCU
now in the comics Lilith is Dracula's
daughter but there is something you need
to know in the comics there are
different iterations and interpretations
of the character Lilith and one is
Dracula's daughter and the other is the
mother of demons now what I think
they're going to do for the MCU is
combine these two characters which are
the same characters but again they
usually keep these two facts separate I
think they're going to combine these two
facts because it just makes perfect
sense not only for the movie Blade but
also for the supernatural side this
could also lead her to go up against the
midnight Sun's team which she has in the
comics and she has recently in the game
the midnight Sons but this could tell us
a little bit about who the villain of
the blade movie could be because it
could be Dracula if they are going to
make her the daughter of Dracula that
means they will most likely introduce
Dracula in the blade film now they'll
probably end up killing Dracula in the
film or at least in depth getting rid of
him for a while and who is going to be
left there after his daughter who is
indeed evil and typically in movies when
someone's parents get killed and they
are evil themselves they tend to seek
revenge so this could be what we're in
for with the blade movie the
introduction of Dracula as the main
villain forblade and the introduction of
his daughter inblade as well but will
also go on to become a bigger villain
and a bigger threat now of course the
question is who is going to be dealing
with her and like we've mentioned the
midnight suns are a perfect candidate it
already seems like Marvel Studios has
kind of been hinting and teasing the
midnight suns are coming they've done a
lot with the midnight suns in the comics
and recently in the games like I I
mentioned but now with character
introductions like werewolf by night man
thing Elsa Bloodstone The Blood Baron
and baroness Cromwell the confirmation
that the Punisher is now coming to the
MCU and yes he is still going to be
played by John Bernthal we also have
Moon Knight who I would love to see join
the midnight Suns now of course the
introduction of Blade and of course the
rumor going around that Ghost Rider is
going to enter the MCU sooner rather
than later it seems like all of the
pieces are there for the midnight Suns
we have our team already once when blade
arrives at is and all they need to do is
kind of be put together and we already
have the perfect person to do that the
person who does it in the comics as well
doctor strange and do you want to guess
why the midnight suns were drawn
together by Doctor Strange in the first
place it was to battle Lilith Doctor
Strange called all of these Supernatural
Heroes together just to fight Lilith and
her demonic children the lilin so Lilith
could go on to be a villain for multiple
different projects and let's not forget
that we have Agatha a coven of chaos
coming as well which is supposed to be
dark and heavily centered on Magic
specifically dark magic and of course is
going to be talking about the dark hold
as well which is an incredibly dark
object then we have the Iron Heart
series coming up and the hood is going
to be the main villain of that series
however the hood might be getting his
powers from a deal that he made with
Mephisto however some people have
recently said that this might not be
true but if he is going to be some type
of an apprentice well it is possible
that he could be The Apprentice of
Lilith and they could start to introduce
her into the MCU now much like they're
doing with Kingpin they could do the
same with Lilith they could introduce
her in several projects to be kind of
the big bad of that Supernatural side
and that's where we can kind of see
everything come together for the
midnight Suns essentially it will be
like phase one they'll introduce all of
these characters on their own we already
have Doctor Strange we have Elsa
Bloodstone already we already have Moon
Knight they're about to introduce blade
and then they're going to introduce
Ghost Rider hopefully fingers crossed we
also have clear who in the comics was
married to doctor strange and the two of
them right now are off on a mission to
try and fix an incursion now there's a
lot happening in between now and Secret
Wars and the midnight Suns might not
come until after Secret Wars however
that doesn't mean that they can't start
setting them up and Doctor Strange like
I said is the perfect person to bring
them together kind of like Nick Fury
brought together the first Avengers if
anybody is going to see that the
supernatural side of the MCU is going to
have a big problem with a big villain
it's doctor strange that is pretty much
his job and of course Wong's job as well
because Wong of course is the sorcerer
Supreme right now however there was a
version of Multiverse Madness that had
Wang dine now I'm not saying that Wong
is gonna die eventually but I'm just
saying Doctor Strange might take up the
mantle of sorcerer's Supreme in the MCU
in fact I'm expecting him to at some
point in time so MIA goth is going to be
playing Lilith in the blade movie and
maybe be playing Lilith and many other
projects as well and like I said this
also tells us that Dracula is most most
likely going to be the main villain of
this film so let us know all of your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below what do you think
about this do you like this are you
waiting for the midnight Sons to enter
the MCU let us know you can also follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf